Every living being needs to fight off other living beings that want to feast on
them. So as a multicellular life evolved over billions of years,
it came out with ways to defend itself. Today,
humans have a sophisticated defense network like physical barriers,
defense cells, and weapons factories.
But what are the most important defenses of our body is largely unknown.
The complement system. It evolved over 700 million years ago.
And as an army of over 30 different proteins that work together in a complex and
elegant dance to stop intruders all in all about 15 quintillion of them are
saturating every fluid in your body right now,
guided by nothing but chemistry.
These proteins are one of the most effective weapons we have against invaders.
Many other parts of the immune system are just tools to activate the complement
system. But it's also really dangerous.
Imagine having trillions of little bombs inside your blood,
that could go off at any moment.
So our cells use numerous mechanisms to prevent compliments from accidentally
attacking them. Okay, what exactly does it do?
And what makes it so dangerous?
In a nutshell, the complement system does three things. It cripples enemies.
It activates the immune system and it rips holes in things until they die.
But how after all these are mindless proteins randomly drifting around
without where Lord direction? Well, this is actually part of the strategy.
Complement proteins float around in a sort of passive mode.
They do nothing until they get activated and change their shape in
the world of proteins,
your shape determines what you can and cannot do because shape
determines what you can interact with. And in what way, for example,
in your passive shape, you might do nothing in your active shape. However,
you might, for example, change the shape of other proteins,
activating them so they can activate others mechanisms like this.
One can start cascades that spread very quickly.
Imagine the compliment proteins as being like millions of matches,
very close together. Once one catches fire, it ignites the ones around it.
They ignite more and suddenly you have a big fire to show.
The actual mechanisms of the complement system is a complicated and
overwhelming. So we'll simplify here.
Now let's imagine you cut yourself and a bunch of bacteria,
enter the wound and make it into the surrounding tissue.
Our compliment attack begins with C3. C3 is the first match.
The initial spark that will start our fire and to do that.
C3 needs to switch from passive to active. How happens is complex,
but let's just say it can happen randomly through other complement proteins that
bind to enemies or through antibodies.
All you really need to know is that C3 breaks into two smaller proteins,
C3 and C3 B that are now activated. One of these parts.
The C3 B protein is like a Sicamous our specialized in bacteria,
funky and viruses. It has a fraction of a second to find a victim,
or it will be neutralized by water molecules. If C3 B does find a target,
it anchors itself very tightly to its surface.
And doesn't let go by doing soap. The protein changes its shape again,
and its new shape.
It's now able to grab other proteins and start a small cascade changing its
shape multiple times, adding other complement proteins to itself. Finally,
it transforms itself into a recruiting platform known as C3 converters.
This platform is an expert at activating more C3 proteins that start the
whole cycle. A new an amplification loop begins soon.
Thousands of proteins cover the bacteria for the bacteria.
This is very bad.
It can cripple the bacteria and make them helpless or slow them down.
Imagine being covered by thousands of flies.
But do you remember the other part of C3? The C3,
a protein C3 eight is like a distress beacon.
Thousands of them flood away from the site of battle screaming for attention.
Passive immune cells notice the C3 proteins and awakened from their slumber to
follow the protein tracks to the site of infection,
the more alarm proteins they encounter, the more aggressive they get this way.
Compliment guides,
reinforcements exactly to the place where they're needed the most. So far.
The compliment has slowed down the invaders and called for help.
Now it's beginning to actively help to kill the enemy.
The first immune cells to arrive at the battlefield are phagocytes,
which means cells. That sweater,
you hold trap you in a tiny prison and then kill you with acid,
but swallow an enemy. They need to grab it first,
which is not easy because bacteria prefer not to be grabbed and a sort of
slippery.
But now the compliment that has anchored itself to the bacteria acts as a sort
of glue that makes it easy for the immune cells to catch their victims,
but it gets even better. Imagine being covered in flies again.
Now imagine them turning into wasps.
Another case is about to begin on the surface of the bacteria.
The C3 recruitment platform changes its shape again,
and begins to recruit new proteins together.
They begin the construction of a bigger structure,
a membrane attack complex piece by piece,
new proteins shaped like long Spears,
anchor themselves deep into the bacterias membranes until they rip a hole into
them. That can't be closed again.
Fluids rush into the bacteria and their insides spill out.
They bleed to death.
The remaining bacteria are maimed and distracted by the compliment and quickly
taken care of by the arriving immune cells.
The invasion has been nipped in the bud before it had the opportunity to become
dangerous. You probably didn't even notice it,
but while bacteria are not happy about compliment the enemies,
it might be the most useful against are actually viruses.
Viruses have one problem.
They need to travel from cell to cell outside of cells.
They're basically hoping to randomly bump against a cell to infect by pure
chance.
Here they're completely defenseless and here compliment is able to
intercept and cripple them.
So they become harmless and guide the immune system to disavow them without
compliment virus infections would be a lot more deadly, but wait,
if we have such an effective weapon, why do we have to get sick?
The problem is that in a war, both sides adapt. For example,
when the vaccine virus infects a cell,
it forces it to produce a protein that shuts compliment activation down this
way. The virus creates safe zones around the cells that in fact,
when it kills them and tries to infect more,
it has a higher chance of being successful. Or some bacteria, for example,
can grab certain molecules from the blood that keep the complement system calm
and make themselves invisible. So the complement system,
while being extremely important is only one player in the complex and beautiful
organization. That is our immune system,
a beautiful example of how many mindless things can do smart things
together.
This video was sponsored by you without your direct
support. This channel would not exist.
And it's hard to overstate how grateful we are for that in 2019,
an average quotes cause Kazak video took at least 1,200 hours to produce.
We need months to research and write our scripts,
clear them with experts in Australia and animate every scene from scratch and to
compose original music.
This is only possible through a combination of sponsorships,
your support on Patrion and selling merge like this poster and postcards we made
about the compliment system. If you yourself want to support us,
you can do so by watching, becoming a Patrion and maybe getting a personal bird,
all bike. I seen one of our calendars or posters.
The purpose of court's Cozart is to make the best videos we can and to make
science more approachable. Thank you so much for making this possible.
[Inaudible].